and for Ian Machado Gary for what I
expect I I think I do think he's the
next thing I'm telling you this kid is
that that he has all the talent he's the
next big thing he's the next guy he is
it I'm telling you put that money in the
bank he's your next guy if he's a stock
put your money on Ian Machado Gary he's
the guy he's the [__] dude that being
said what I think where he's gonna get
in his career I need a big finish over
Neil magni that's my only knock on him
ah in this showcase fight a sugar Shawn
card Al Joe there's two main event two
basic Main Events two title fights above
you you're leading into that we got to
get a finish so even that I know I'm
being hard on but even that's like Neil
magni is a Savage he didn't that fight
wasn't competitive dude in any facet
that's how goody and Machado Gary is I'm
telling you you guys need to be all in
on imacado Gary